Short and sweet number nine.
We learned how if a person would mix kosher wine with other ingredients to the extent that the flavor of the wine had been affected
and it no longer tastes like wine, it would no longer be subject to the laws of Stam Yeinam,
in which case if a non-Jew would touch it, it would not become forbidden.
However, we did say that the wine must be mixed well and it can no longer be visible and the flavor has to be altered.
If it's not the case, and let's say for example we had was a dressing where wine and honey was mixed together
And the wine did not mix well, and it was just sitting on top of the honey, and it's visible, and it was not altered because it's not really mixed well with the honey, and then a non-Jew would touch that wine, that would be a problem of Stam Yeinam, that would be a problem and be prohibited.
In a situation where non-mivushal kosher wine was mixed with water at a ratio of 1 to 6, we said that it is no longer considered wine anymore and is not subject to the laws of Stam Yeinam.
If a person would freeze or congeal wine to an extent where it's a salad, it is no longer subject to the laws of Stam Yeinam. It's not something that would be libated.
However, once it melts and it's back in its liquid form, it is subject to the laws of Stam Yeinam, and we were not really sure exactly at what point it's considered a liquid again.
The example we said was a slushy. Is that a solid? Is that a liquid?
So a person should be careful if they have a frozen wine at an event, which is Namavushel,
they should make sure not to allow any non-juice to come in contact with it as it starts to melt.
We said that if a person has pottery or a barrel which had absorbed Stam Yeinam into the walls,
and to the extent that if the water was left in the barrel, it would then get flavor from the wine,
So then, the water would be forbidden from getting any benefit from, it has the flavor of the Stam Yeinam, which was absorbed in the walls of the pottery or the barrel, and therefore would be prohibited to benefit.
Which brought us to the next conversation of sherry cask whiskey.
We said sherry cask whiskey is produced by aging the whiskey in barrels which had been used in the past to store sherry wine, which of course is Stam Yeinam.
The question was, is this going to be prohibited or permissible?
We had many reasons to forbid this sherry cask whiskey.
The first reason was because, again, as we just mentioned, the sherry gets absorbed into the barrel,
and then when the whiskey sits in the barrel for at least more than 24 hours, it would then get some flavor from the sherry.
So the first question we said, well, is the flavor buttle in the whiskey?
Well, according to the Shach, the whiskey must be 60 times the sherry flavor,
We also then had to discuss, well, how much sherry? Do we have to be Mibato? Is the entire width of the barrel filled with the sherry flavor? Or is it just a Kedek Lipa? Well, if you go with the Shach's understanding of the Shulchan Aruch, it's the entire width of the barrel.
Another reason to forbid it, because there is no way you are going to have 60 times the entire width of a barrel with the contents of the barrel.
Another reason to ask or to forbid is we said that since the sherry is presumably being added to the whiskey,
you specifically want the whiskey to sit in the sherry cask in order to get flavor,
and something which is added for flavor is never bitul,
so even if you would have 60 times the amount, it would never be bitul because it is specifically being done to add flavor.
Similarly, another issue was anything that is added for chazusa, for color, is never bitul,
And if, again, we assume that the sherry cask serves a function of adding color to the whiskey, that would also introduce another issue.
And lastly, even if a person would come up with a scenario where the sherry is batal, it is nullified in the whiskey,
but then we said there could be a problem of purchasing this whiskey by relying on the bitul,
which could be a problem of imi batal and isser l'chachila, of deliberately nullifying a prohibition, which is a problem.